good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday happy
hump day do not forget i know it's easy
to forget but do not forget to hump
someone you love today it's especially
easy to forget today since neither do
nor brew are here today i had like a
feeling of maybe bringing brew but you
know it's just so much work and i had oh
you're telling me no but dew is a
full-grown adult still so much work he
takes himself to work he packs his
briefcase it's still back he brings his
lunch with back breaking rue it's like a
little baby i'm coming up on my one year
anniversary of brews homecoming your one
year branniversary my one year brand
anniversary like my time hop yesterday
it's like the crate getting set up and
like i'm just i remember those days i
think it's like six days till the
anniversary and i'm literally just gonna
like cry all day like i'm so it's just
so crazy this journey that i've been on
in the last year
and what this man brew has brought to my
life and what his role in the journey
was and i don't know if anyone out there
is thinking about getting a puppy right
now and i know it's a lot of
responsibility and a lot of work yes but
i just need to let you know
i don't remember any of that i only
remember the love it has been worth it
on every single level and brew actually
took kind of a long time to get trained
and you know sometimes he still has his
moments and i wouldn't trade it for the
world so if you're looking for a sign to
get a puppy or even you know a cat or no
this is not a sign to get a cat a
hamster sure a pet of any sort a pet
rock do it because
it will change your life
i couldn't echo that sentiment any
harder if i tried i mean i mean i've
been like trying to tell ever on this
like forever like that first year it is
hard you know not to
minimize minimize it's hard but my god
is it worth it it's and you know what
now looking back at the year like that
portion where brew literally needed to
go out every 30 minutes
feels like it was you know a dream no
but it feels like it was such a short
period of time they just need to grow a
little bit to get the bladder bigger and
then they can hold it for longer but at
that time it was just still so exciting
and i just
i'm feeling you know very
grateful for the brew in my life
i absolutely love to hear that happy
anniversary to bruno to you zach the
whole family we'll be celebrating the
whole week so i think we're going to do
seven days of brew
unfortunately i am gone for the next
seven days so i will ben said he was
gonna be happy to celebrate for the
first three days because he loves being
an uncle to bro even though i think he's
met him like three times no ben loves
bro he does yeah he talks about bruno
all the time he said that yeah no he
literally doesn't even know bruce no not
at all um but speaking of ben today is
my last show of the week because i'm
headed to roma to eat some spaghetti you
know i was actually thinking this
morning i do not know like one thing i
don't know how to say anything in italy
italian yeah you do
chow chow um
bella i should have done babble
it's not too late do it on the plane
because like this classes are snackable
traveling to a country where you don't
know like and even like you know
where's the bathroom like it's kind of
dangerous or no
i think i'm fluent
you should you babble on the plane a
hundred basketball classes today's not
sponsored by babel i was just thinking
last night how i legit don't know like
one lick of italian but ben is filling
in for me tomorrow friday and monday so
if you have something you've been
wanting to ask ben or just something
you've been thinking about getting ben's
take on let us know
yeah ben is full of takes he is full of
taking they're usually terrible i look
forward to hearing what he brings to the
table you know i do love an out of the
box take i do so otbt yes so i am here
for whatever he wants to bring to the
show no youtube will get along
swimmingly like ben like when it comes
when i ask him to like form an opinion
on like toe stuff or just in general
when he's having like an opinion on
something he'll come up with like the
worst take ever just because like he
wants to be like contrarian and
different and you know that element i do
respect but the take is so bad you can't
just do it for the sake of doing it you
know can i be honest with you sometimes
it feels like you have your like
controversial takes like just for the
sake of being a contrarian and that's
your feeling and that's not fact i don't
do it for the sake of it i do it because
i think most of the time if everybody's
saying the exact same thing and it seems
too simple and too good to be true you
know there's multiple sides to every
story and you've got to look at it from
a layered perspective
sure and i think you should apply that
to all areas of your life some things
aren't so simple and sometimes the
majority
they don't know what they got it wrong
no i mean that's definitely true but
it's not like all the time no i mean
sometimes i'm just like yeah happy for
them period
you're full of hot takes so it should be
a very interesting week with you in bed
i mean it makes for an interesting show
100
so that's thursday friday and monday
with ben i'll be back on tuesday try not
to miss me so much i am really i'm
actually going to watch i can't do babel
on the plane i'm going to watch the
lizzie mcguire movie before i fall
asleep i kind of just need some
inspiration from miss ungermeier
that's what i'm going to do okay have
fun and i'm going to
listen to the soundtrack and i actually
if you have any good um captions like
lizzie mcguire i like forgot all like i
don't even remember what happened in the
movie i just wanna watch the movie
sneaky brown knows her with a hidden
agenda agenda but if you went to rome
and you have like
some good captions that you use that are
like lizzie mcguire miss under meyer
like references do send them my way
because i'm i'm curious you're about to
watch a movie you're going to know that
no no just because i watch a movie i
need like creative like maybe ideas for
tick tocks like something if you have if
you have any ideas just send them my way
okay do you plan on doing a lot of
content on this trip 100
cool and it's going to be all liz
mcguire like what else is there to do in
rome except talk about the liz mcguire
movie
that's true what other movies take place
in rome like none
um
what's that anna faris movie what hap
no not
something about rome
do you know what i'm talking about it's
like one of her a million like rom-coms
i think like josh jumel was in it i
don't it's like they built what is that
movie hold on
romantic comedies
do you know what i'm talking about
romantic comedy realm
is um
am i making this movie up in my head
yeah because it doesn't ring a bell and
i'm quite familiar with her catalog no
but maybe not anna faris but like
one of those girls like what's it about
like rome i don't know
there's like a wedding in rome
like he's gonna be your date honestly it
didn't come up i haven't seen it but
it's not to roam with love i don't even
know what that is
there's a sarah jessica parker movie all
roads lead to rome that's not it
maybe i am just like making it what is
it one with britney murphy and ashton
kutcher where they're like jelly wedges
oh yeah yeah yeah oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
um
honeymoon they're on their honeymoon
what's that movie called google it that
is the best movie it isn't in rome it's
rome vibes okay it could be you know
like milan you know that movie is like
always playing on e movies we love
what is this called
just married okay where does it take
place
everywhere
just married okay
so it was nominated for a golden globe
what
okay it doesn't have like their
itinerary on here but i don't think that
they went to why the movie made a
hundred million dollars
was that good it was people no quality
oh venice oh not rome
same but different same but different
but yeah so like if you have any good i
don't know so the only cultural
reference i know is the lizzie mcguire
movie
if you have any good captions that you
use and like got like so many likes on
like let me know because i want to steal
it okay cool simple enough because
obviously the first one is like me at
the trevi fountain feeling like a sneaky
brown-noser with a hidden agenda
why does that have to be chubby fountain
cause that's like so rome okay i mean i
guess i could just like geotag but like
i wanted to be like this really roman
picture and like for me what i think
rome i think sneaky brown knows her with
a hidden agenda okay okay what do you
think of
um
[Music]
oh also euro trip
but like i don't really like know that
movie yeah or the references except
they've elected a new pup wouldn't like
the white smoke comes out yeah that'll
be one of my captions too
okay perfect i'm starting you're good to
go no like so they're gonna have to take
a lot of pictures do you think your
friends are up to the task like your
husband's not going okay so ben's need
he's not going okay but i have abe
oh okay abe is like one of my my best
friends from high school and he's very
like actually very artsy and he can take
a pic okay and it's he knows he's been
tasked like because i got so many
dresses like i'm gonna look so cute
except like i did get this gown that i
fully intend to re-wear like
maybe to three more weddings and i'm
thinking i actually won't take any
pictures at the actual wedding in the
dress like for my instagram yeah i think
that's a good idea because i don't know
how everyone's keeping up with all these
weddings like dresses everything like
everything on revolve is on back order
like you can't get a gown on revolve
until literally december that's true i
actually just had to order some dresses
and of course the ones that i liked were
on pre-order of course it didn't help
anything but i do feel like i was
actually just thinking about this i do
feel like it's easier than ever to get
dresses like i remember when i was in
college like you would have formal and
like you would have to borrow a dress
from a friend right right now these
girls just have a revolving door of
revolve packages with like formal
dresses i never went to a formal like
you haven't lived really what was it
what did they do it was just like it was
like a college party but it was formal
so like everyone dressed up everyone
dressed up like what did i wear like
suit very nice and you had a date so
there was like a romantic element and so
some people just like invited a friend
for formal but like sometimes it was
like if you had a crush on someone and
like they have a formal are they going
to invite you
and how many times how frequent with
formals so like each
return each group would have like one a
season so like two a year per house so
there's a lot of formals going around
and how many houses are and sometimes
they would have it depends on the school
right
and also i'm sure that depends on the
school too but also sometimes they would
have like a a formal and a semi-formal
like they had the big one and a smaller
one so it's just like was really cool
how many four ones did you go to and
when you asked someone to a formal is it
like a big deal or did you like send it
to me attack you said to be attacked
okay but like it's a big deal but they
don't make like a big problem
um
how many forms did i i went to a fair
share of foreign gal who got asked
because honestly i think
as much as it sounds really fun
i'm so hurtful i think i'm so grateful i
went to nyu because like okay let's say
all of you it's okay there's so many you
have to be invited to everyone but like
all your friends are going to one and
then you're like scrambling to find a
date like some pathetic loser but like
it never really happened in such a sad
way like that for example if all of you
but it would happen for me no but like
if all of your friends were going then
they were all going with like a group of
guys who were friends say and then there
was more than likely someone in their
group of friends who didn't have a date
and would invite you right like it
usually worked out like that um but
sometimes you like went to a formal
where you didn't know anyone you know
because you have something because you
just like you're taking a leap on the
unknown man that's painful no but like
it's just that's the closest you'll get
to romance
but if i'm a guy
and like i want to invite a girl who
like knows everyone because like i want
to be babysitting yeah there's that too
so like you could get us just a friend
like a social internet so you can get
like actually i feel like i might be
invited a lot because i'm just like
playing this out i went to nyu like i
just actually feel like i might have
been invited to a lot of formals because
like you don't have to worry about me
like you can go i don't even need to
talk to you like drop me off i'll meet a
new guy hang out with my friends but
like you'll have a date but you won't
have to babysit man like we can have the
best time like if you need to go do your
thing like i'm good on my own yes only
thing is like he might want to have sex
um with someone no i'm not gonna be you
no definitely not um so like
oh so interesting there's like this
whole part of your life like and also
sometimes there would be like depend not
on us for a formal formal but for some
of the like more casual formals there
would sometimes just be like a socialist
of people girl like people because guys
are people at the party guys or girls
who were invited who weren't anyone's
date we just like them so got it got it
that could be your
oh by the way i'm like the head of the
social committee for sure yeah and like
i keep the list
love that you know i was watching a tick
tock that was like you know top 10
schools that consume the most beer
number one was like university of
wisconsin colgate was like number four
that's crazy because the population is
so small small it's like three thousand
max that's crazy yo great that's a lot
of beer
i didn't contribute to any of it yeah
never actually we did keg stands that
one time
we did yeah we took pictures you did you
did one too i don't know if i did you
definitely did one maybe for the picture
but still i was definitely not drinking
some of my fondest memories are those
weekends that we used to visit you at
college oh what a time what a place and
just to clarify i just don't drink beer
i drank like
things i just i'm not a beer girly uh in
my old age i actually have started to
enjoy it quite a bit you have you know
it's just like
something that
i don't that i'm just trying to
reconcile it's like my college years
were just a few
years off
from like canned cocktails yeah like
white claws white cloth society society
like that would have changed my college
experience if like i didn't always have
to like pre-game before because there
wasn't gonna be about the party yeah
like because some schools like banhart
alcohol like oh my god there was so much
chaos surrounding like trying to get a
drink if you weren't a beer drinker and
that like white club just solved that
100 and like now if you go i mean i
haven't been to a college party but i
imagine there's just cases of like truly
white cloth
i can't even imagine i agree like that
is a game changer and honestly
that's such a good call yeah i think
about it often i'm happy for the kids
now but you know i really would have
been just like my whole life would have
been different totally um but we have an
amazing show for you guys it is my last
show of the week so i'm just gonna try
and make it my best one yet we do have a
juicy tv recap we've got vader pump
rules which i did catch up on and last
night's episode was fine
last night was also the season finale of
only murders in the building the most
perfect show on television most perfect
we watch it and i also i did watch the
new episode of impeachment me and ben
then ben literally stumbled and he's
like is impeachment on he doesn't even
remember my birthday like but he knows
that you know tuesday at nine o'clock is
impeachment and i was like i don't know
and we recorded it and it was on and it
was so good so now you're watching week
to week you think i mean i didn't plan
on it but ben all of a sudden is like
this timely person and we watch it and
it didn't i mean i would love to just
binge it it's so good and when the
episode ends i'm like depressed
so
we'll see moving forward how i handle it
but i would love for it to just be
dropped like leave it like it's enough
and when you watch on fx there's
commercials like it's not a premium
experience but then it goes to hulu the
next day yeah but i use actual piro's
hulu and he don't have that like extra
subscription i'm about to like just
click it for him um but i bought the
whole season on itunes so like i just
already they download them automatically
got it i have them all recorded on my tv
so i'll watch that way can i tell you
like how unenjoyable it is to skip
through the commercials like when i
watch on itunes it was literally like a
film it's like an hour long there's like
it goes black and then it comes and you
have to do anything and last night i was
like every five minutes like
with the clicker like it's so annoying
so annoying these are some tough times
we're living in so that will be the tv
recap segment we've got the fast five
and i
don't have anything else to say unless
you do
no i had a lovely evening of nesting
last night i cooked like so i started
because i just wanted to make a salad to
go with my dressing i was still in the
fridge and then i was like i have some
chicken let's cook that up and then i
was like we need a starch made some
pasta so i really um created a whole
culinary experience it looked really
good it was really good and when i'm so
funny like i just decided like four
o'clock i'm like time to cook dinner and
then i go to get zach and he's like
still on calls and i'm just like he just
had lunch i'm like
it's like 5 30 he's like still working
and i'm like why don't you want to eat
my meal and it's like because you
started cooking at four o'clock like i
just don't plan at all so i got to get
better about that but it's like i don't
do the cooking for like meal times they
do it because it's an activity obviously
so
that's just that was fun and then i read
a lot last night i'm reading apple's
never fall by leanne moriarty you know
her
she's big little lies nine perfect
strangers husband's secret husband
secret what else forgot which is still
my favorite leanne moriarty book but
maybe it's just because it was the first
one that i read
and i'm really enjoying apple's number
four for some reason the description
like made me think it was spooky about
like a murder it's not spooky at all
and i just like love her voice leanne
moriarty like i was cracking up this
character that's like the mom of the
family it's just so funny and she's like
the house is so quiet now that all her
kids are grown so she listens to
podcasts like on her like beats head
morning toes all throughout the day so
that she can be and her daughter has
like migraines so she listens to like
living with migraines and it's like
she's such a she's hysterical so
i'm really enjoying the book hopefully i
finish it like today i've been on a
reading like bit plowing through reading
well i haven't but i am charging my
kindle for my trip and i was thinking
that i wanted to read excuse me excuse
me
bless you
that i wanted to read the new housewives
book by david we're going to talk about
it in the stories okay because i want to
talk about to read or not to read okay
same so then i'll save what i was going
to say okay um and i also have beach
read on deck that's all i was going to
say i haven't read it yet
i liked it when i read it
i don't know if that's your next book
we'll talk about it okay then give me
some like just generic you know
murder
thrill romance something like silly you
know like what was that book about the
girl who got married in nantucket but
then there was a murder at the wedding
um that was was it ellen hildebrand yeah
27
the perfect couple the perfect couple
yeah like that you know okay okay i'm
going through something nonsensical
nonsensical
i'm looking i've been i've had such a
weird year of reading jackie my flight
is at 5 30 and i get in at 7 00 a.m
that room time like do you sleep the
whole time
well you'll sleep as lot much as you can
yeah but like should i take like a
sleeping pill
and just like try and sleep the eight
hours so i wake up like we're fresh 7am
in rome
yikes i know
i don't know or do you sleep a little
bit more when you get to the hotel till
like 11. yeah but like once i'm in rome
i just want to you know be a sneaky
brownnoser with my hidden agenda that is
true do you read the good sister by
sally hepworth no i didn't it's really
good okay done i think that's the one we
stand sally hepworth in this house we
really do i need to like go read some of
her other books
but before i can do that without further
ado it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
i just remembered i didn't put on
deodorant today that does not have
anything to do with today's sponsor i
just you know when like you lift your
armpits and there's like a little
moisture no not moisture i wouldn't say
moisture actually i would say more of
like a textured stickiness
you know like when you like lift and
like the flaps of your armpits like are
sticking together yep yep and then i'm
like oh yeah i didn't put on deodorant
today's episode is brought to you by
modern fertility did you know that a
simple fingerprint can unlock tons of
insight into your reproductive health
we're talking egg count menopause timing
if your hormone levels indicate
conditions like thyroid disorders or
even pcos so these are all good things
to know
whether or not kids are in your future
and there's so much about fertility
that's a complete mystery and that's
where modern fertility hormone tests
come in think of your fertility hormones
as tiny detectives that can bring you
tons of insight into your egg count
reproductive timeline and even possible
outcomes for egg freezing and ivf it's
everything you need to know to get
proactive about your fertility
so you can get really important
fertility insight without going to the
doctor or even leaving your house modern
fertility makes it possible with easy at
home fertility hormone testing
um
it's time for a new type of education
that puts your reproductive goals front
and center so the traditional guidance
with fertility has always been just wait
and see but now we have tools to help us
plan and track for everything in our
lives
and fertility is absolutely no different
knowledge is power so the more you know
you can make better decisions for your
body your health your future you
probably thought that the next step in
your career and your relationship but
what about next step for planning kids
women are having children later in life
but biology has not changed so modern
fertility is an easy and affordable way
to test your fertility hormones at home
with a simple finger prick you mail it
in with a prepaid label you'll get your
personalized test results within 10 days
the traditional testing at your doctor
can cost over a thousand dollars but
modern fertility gets you the same
information at 159
and if you go to modernfertility.com
toast you can get 20 off your test also
if you have an hsa or an fsa you can put
those dollars towards modern fertility
so modern fertility is offering our
listeners 20 off the test when you go to
modernfertility.com
toast which means that 159 test is now
going to cost you 139
um
so get that 20 off your fertility test
at modernfertility.com
toast
toast
okay our first story just this has been
a roller coaster you guys and right now
we're on another
i would say we're going up we're
climbing la la can is home with randall
according to tmz and not calling off the
engagement yet lala and randall are
trying to save their engagement tmz has
learned they're at home together working
on their relationship even as rumors fly
that they've split sources familiar with
the situation tell tmz that lala and
randall have not broken broken off their
engagement despite reports to the
contrary they're told lala went to the
beverly hills hills hotel on sunday
night and stayed there as part of a
planned night out with her girlfriends
and she's now back home in the couple's
bel-air estate
and according to like the instagram
photos that they've been posting it does
look like
referencing the pictures she's posted it
actually looks like that's in their
house they also have a podcast and they
released a podcast episode yesterday um
and mentioned nothing of this well it
probably was pre-recorded um i read
somewhere that it was like just recorded
but i don't there's no proof of that
yeah i feel like they probably recorded
it even a few days ago but then also so
i saw this article from tmz and i was
feeling so hopeful because i you know
tmz is usually
pretty truthful
so i was like okay this is really good
news and then also did you see that
randall posted a video of two girls like
working in his office
are those the two girls from nashville
so we're trying to make are they truly
just working on business so he was in
the nashville um lobby with a blonde and
brunette and in his office are blonde
and brunette and he posted them not
saying anything but i think wanting us
to like
infer that but there is other damning
evidence from this situation it's not
just those photos i believe there are
text messages floating around um
so he's not completely out of the woods
yet but i don't know like
you know sheena said something really
[ __ ] mean on on um vanderpump rules
last night
when he when or maybe it was two
episodes ago because i just caught up
when randall was like no i don't change
diapers and she was like
sheena and her confessionals was like i
could never be with someone who like
refuses to change a diaper no matter how
much money he has i guess lala can be
bought yeah no she keeps saying mean
stuff about lala and her confessionals
they must not be friends right now
that's like a really mean thing to say
yeah and weirdly enough last night on
banner pump rules this sort of
conversation came up between la la and
china where yeah um
lala was pretty much telling sheena like
how you get them is how you lose them
and also lala to herself is like and i
understand that about my situation and
it's like a concern of mine right like
that's it's something that lives in the
back of my head and like i actually i
think a lot of people saw that scene
where like oh how ironic but
what moral high ground do you have lala
but i thought i had a lot of respect for
her like owning it completely yeah they
are like how can you talk about bra
considering what's going on in your
relationship now but it's like watching
that scene lala has such a good head on
her shoulders and the fact and it's true
so many times people get into a
relationship you know they were married
or separated and then
and the saying goes how you get them is
how you lose them and and while is aware
of that doesn't mean she's not going to
be with randall or give him a chance but
like it's not something that she's going
to like blissfully be delusional about
yeah so i actually thought that it was
the perfect scene to watch while we're
all like dealing with this news because
it's like oh whatever regardless of what
happens like she's gonna be fine nothing
is going to surprise you no and lala
didn't think that like this was out of
the realm of possibility and lana's not
living her life like randall is like
will be there forever and i don't need
to do anything ever like she's and
that's really what like sheena does like
with everyone yeah she has multiple
businesses like i think she's always you
know
planning on taking care of herself if it
ever comes to that so
i don't know what's going on between
lala rand i'm i'm feeling extremely
hopeful this is some good news
for the landlord stands our ship you
guys it's not sinking like i think it's
moralla
it's whatever you want it to be and i
i'm feeling like for once you know my
optimism has paid off you know you're
always like delusionally optimistic and
like more often than not like kim and
kanye like the world lets you down so
like you needed this with kim and kanye
i actually think my
optimism protected me because i never
really had to deal like so when everyone
was reporting that they were
separating divorcing and they never
confirmed it i was like okay well they
haven't confirmed it so it's like i
don't have to grieve yet because it
might not be
and then by the time she did share it on
keeping up i was way more prepared to
yes of course soften the blow and then i
was like okay so that's true like
they're not together but this isn't now
new news to me like i'm okay with it and
now they're in a place where they're so
simpatico that it's like i never had to
grieve i skipped the grieving process
that's true and now i'm so familiar with
the idea of them not being together like
separate but like simpatico yeah and so
it's the best case scenario sometimes
your optimism can protect you i do think
lala and randall will probably be fine
yeah um that's just like a gut
feeling of mine i have no proof of that
but um i would love some clarification
on what the [ __ ] going on for sure she
was also spotted walking without her
engagement ring on but she was also like
not dressed up so maybe she just like
didn't put her jewelry on i just want to
say i can't abide by that
like okay i literally i hate when people
like she wasn't wearing her ring like
it's
maybe for a guy it means something
because like ben never takes his ring
off he like sleeps and it showers in it
if i'm home my ring is off if i'm
running to the grocery store my ring is
off like so all these paparazzi pictures
like spotted without her ring means
literally nothing absolutely zilch zilch
um i mean i think sometimes celebrities
like use it as like a
tool to let us know what's going on
they're at the grocery store with like a
sponsored beverage in hand and no ring
like okay they're trying to tell us
something but if it's truly a paparazzi
like catching you in your natural state
yeah at the grocery store getting a
coffee and you're not wearing your ring
to me that means absolutely nothing
means nothing i completely agree so
there's still hope between the two of
them and maybe they are going through a
rough patch like maybe those pictures
text messages were just like
you know
uh
a warning sign and maybe they're gonna
work it out i'm gonna i'm gonna go with
tmz because it's tmc staying there
together and page six is saying that
they split so those are two
kind of as far as you know tabloids go
they're kind of reputable sources yeah i
mean honestly but considering this one
landing
i'm going to go with tmz i agree h6 says
the new york t but i do believe tmz's
got it covered in california why would
randall cheat on lala like honestly i
was watching her and like she is so
gorgeous like i forget what i was
watching i think when they were
sitting out playing jenga in palm
springs and she was wearing like this
gorgeous hat and sunglasses and like a
little black bathing suit i'm like
there's literally nobody in the world
who's more gorgeous and she just had a
baby like
what else is out there and she's got the
personality like she's really the full
package will keep it interesting you'll
always be laughing like she is
everything of the sort i agree but you
know what like when a man is a serial
cheater like that like it doesn't make
sense right they don't do it based on
logic right they just they've got
problems yeah
so that is so lame like honestly serial
cheater like that's not a thing yeah
just don't cheat on your wife don't be
married that's what like the page six is
saying that he has this like two sides
to him i don't know if he's a serial
cheater no but like okay that's a thing
like serial cheater and it's just like
don't cheat on your wife like it's
really not that hard especially when she
just had a baby yeah
yeah ocean is mad cute
beyond
so we'll see we shall see but you
actually time will tell
i'm feeling better than i did at the
outset i'm glad
our next story
the executive producer for bravo's real
housewives of beverly hills claims lisa
vanderpump leaked the puppy gate story
obviously okay so
a new real housewives tell-all book
called not all diamonds and rose has
just dropped by david quinn dave quinn
sorry i don't know him like that and
there are just you know bombs aplenty
it's like an oral history of the
beginning of real housewives of a lot of
the things that we've seen so one is
that the
beverly hills producer saying that when
lisa lost the narrative in the show and
she realized that it wasn't going the
way she wanted that's when she leaked
the story to the press about lucy lucy
apple juicy okay so let's talk about
lucy louise apple juicy and then let's
talk about other bombs just the book in
general yeah so obviously lisa
vanderpump leaked that whole to read dog
rescue thing that's the least surprising
thing of all time but you know when i
was watching vanderpump rules last night
i was thinking a lot about lisa
vanderpump like my god what a
irrelevant person like talk about a fall
from grace you know she thought she was
too good for the housewives she like
didn't even show up at the end but she
had this like sickening franchise she
didn't need it vandenberg is like
imploded on its own
she got her own show that was like
actually i think detrimental to her
reputation that's how like
embarrassingly
the embarrassing the
ratings were and she's just like kind of
like flop central now like what in where
in the world is lisa vanderpump yeah
it's true i mean and still seeing her
like hanging out with these children on
vanderpump rules and she's like making
fun of james's ring because he said i
got it from tiffany's and he didn't like
what are you doing like you're a grown
[ __ ] woman i don't know it's it's
pretty sad and
i guess i the thing is when someone like
is lying so blatantly like you know kyle
came to her house like ask her as a
friend did you leak it and she's like no
like you at certain point it's like okay
maybe she didn't yeah that's always an
element in your mind so reading this it
is a little bit surprising that like
after all like she died on that hill for
that lie i really did even though like
in hindsight she's the only one who
talks to radar online like they used
words that like she uses that were like
weirdly specific words like it was
written in her voice duh but still at
the time i was like well did she or was
it someone in her camp you know but like
nope it was her and was it john from
vanderpump dogs right exactly or someone
who like overheard her speaking and then
ran and told radar online and the same
words that she used you know
but no it's not sometimes the answer is
the simplest one i just feel like she
went out in such a coward-like way and
she's really just gone downhill from
there yeah for like in so many ways like
every time there's something about her
in the press it's never flattering when
the women do refer to her it's like in
the most negative way
vanderpump rules is a fraction of what
it used to be a shell of the show it
used to be and it's just like honestly
lisa vader pump is kind of irrelevant
like she is you just love to see it yeah
i mean vanderpump rules is not like our
favorite show anymore but still i guess
she does have like
her own show on bravo okay but when she
left beverly hills i think that she had
the
um energy to do it because she was
literally an executive producer of the
biggest show on television like
vanderpump rules for so long was this
like
rocket ship like everyone was obsessed
like everyone on the show was having all
the success at least it was like the
girl and now it's just like a regular
show like everyone else like a losery
reality show that doesn't have
the longevity that it used to mm-hmm
yeah so some of the other stuff that's
come out from the book that i've seen so
far
okay carol versus andy um
some spat there i'm sorry i just like
can't be bothered to care but did you
see that a lot of the women from new
york said that bethany was the one who
set up the picture of tom kissing
another woman at the regency what so
apparently this is what they're saying
allegedly i don't want to hear this
stuff like i want to read it in the book
oh you so you do want to read okay we'll
talk about the book but then i also want
to ask like if i should read the book
and i'll give you my my
reasoning on why same for me this is
what i read that i guess bethany's
friend like
bethany had a friend who bethany knew
was like in communication with tom and
so she like kind of orchestrated them
getting together at the regency and
kissing and that's how she got the photo
because she kind of set it up as opposed
to like randomly her friend was at the
regency and got a picture of it i don't
know i believe this time people thought
it might have been production that told
bethany about it but
more sinisterly some of the women are
saying that bethany actually like knew
about the whole setup if it's coming
from the real housewives of new york
they're such jealous women and they're
they like hate bethany i don't really
believe that bethany has like a lot
going on like she was dealing with her
custody battle and her million dollar
business and her child like i don't know
if she has time to set up tom in the
regency
yeah i don't know either i don't totally
believe it but i could see a situation
where it's like bethany knew they all
had their uh concerns about tom and
bethany knew that she had a friend who
was like tom was talking to her and she
was like wait would tom really do this
and so she was like go meet up with him
like do whatever you want to do um
and
was maybe trying to give him the benefit
of the doubt that he wouldn't like make
out with her in public but then when he
did like and she got the picture because
her reaction i'm sorry that's not acting
like she was literally like genuine
panic attack like i think maybe even if
she did set it up which i don't think
it's possible she didn't but even if she
did i think maybe he thought she thought
that like that wouldn't be the outcome
i do not think it was like a test that
he failed i don't think that she had
anything to do with it because if the
only proof is coming from like ramona
singer and dorinda luanne they hate
bethany they hate her i don't believe
that at all but part of the reason why
i'm struggling with this book because
there is a bunch of good tea coming up
but i feel like i've heard it already
like the big things are this that you
just told me uh lisa vanderpump
selling lucy lucy apple juicy and then
like carol and angie do not talk anymore
she went absolutely ballistic on andy um
so i feel like i've heard like the
juiciest pieces and my concern is that
this book is published by andy cohen
books it's like their first book ever
it's like his
imprint
and
i can't imagine that it would be that
juicy because first of all
there's probably a lot of juice around
andy and like andy had to approve all
this book like it's it's gonna be a very
flattering book for andy um and i don't
know i feel like it's just it's not
gonna go there like a hundred percent
because it's like an andy book if that
makes sense i think it'll go there on
stuff that happened so long ago that's
irrelevant like sure we'll get the t on
what happened between gina keough and
like i don't who cares i know and the
book i saw andy hold it up on watch what
happened inside this massive
so maybe like so i don't want i'm not
downloading that on my kindle no i was
actually thinking it's much more of a
physical read and it's like maybe a cute
like thing to put on your coffee table
and like maybe you just
i agree it's too big to put on a kindle
like it's overwhelming it's like a
textbook it's a textbook so
my conclusion was that i wasn't going to
read it because
i
like i don't think i'm that level of
housewife fan anymore
i've got to read the books too i mean so
sometimes like when a book comes out
that's like has bombshells and you see
in like every news article another day
another bombshell like jessica sims and
he's like oh my god i have to read this
i'm not even going to look at the
spoilers this doesn't feel that way to
me i'm like i'm happy to just get the
nuggets from the news well to be honest
it's such a thick book and i feel like
so much of it is about orange county
because it really was the first
franchise i know that vicky's like very
involved in the book as is scott dunlop
who dirt produced and produces
um orange county and like to be honest
like i really don't care about orange
county like not in the slightest to me
the first franchise is in new york i'm
like you want to fight me on that that's
fine like i know that orange county was
like a year or two before but
the new york women put the show on the
map yeah if this book had come out a few
years ago i probably would have read it
um
but i just don't feel like i i don't
have the reverence for the show that i
once did i agree so i don't really care
about the tea and if it was like shorter
i might have read it but it does feel
weird because didn't brian moylan just
write a book like this
yeah
um the real story of the real housewives
yeah is that part of it andy's it's no
so it feels like this is like
the more in-depth version
yeah but andy was so involved with this
book it gives it like the stamp of
approval
yes but then also so you it makes you
wonder like you know it's definitely
been vet yes right
okay i'm looking at brian brian
are they putting stuff in there about
how much everyone's getting paid like
that's the [ __ ] i want to know
yeah i don't know
i wonder if the book's gonna do well i
feel like it will and they're like bravo
and everyone every housewife was at the
party last night like everyone is giving
it a hundred percent i'm sure it will do
well yeah there's tons of fans um we're
gonna continue on with our stories but
not before i let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by shipstation
the holidays are coming up and if you're
selling anything online it's time to
prepare for the busiest time of year
between growing your business managing
inventory and juggling orders you've got
a lot going on this holiday season so
make shipping the easiest part of your
day with ship station so if you have an
etsy shop you poshmark anything on like
a side hustle or your main business make
jewelry the holidays are nuts like
there's so many delays with shipping you
got to get on top of it and i highly
recommend ship station figuring out the
best way to ship your orders can be
frustrating but ship station makes it
quick easy and convenient you easily
import your orders from any sales
channel automate just about any shipping
task so you spend less time sorting
through orders and more time doing what
you do best
ships ship station integrates all
selling channels into one simple
dashboard so you can seamlessly connect
carriers print shipping labels and get
products to the door fast over a hundred
thousand sellers you use shipstation in
their business
and they work with all the major
carriers and give you exclusive
discounts on ups and usps so you can
compare carriers and choose the best
solution for you and your customers with
ship stations small businesses can now
access the same rates that are usually
reserved for fortune 500 companies so
again if you have an etsy shop an ebay
store poshmark any business where you
sell check out ship station it will make
your life a thousand times easier it's
never too early to start prepping for
the holiday rush so get a head start
with ship station our listeners can use
code toast to get a 60 day free trial
just in time for the holidays that's two
months of stress-free holiday shopping
for free holiday shipping excuse me for
free just go to ship station click on
the microphone at the top and enter in
toast ship station make ship happen
love it okay i love a
punny slogan we do love it our next
story celine dion has been forced to
delay her las vegas residency over
severe muscle spasms celine dion is
delaying the opening of her new
residency because of severe and
persistent muscle spasms she announced
on tuesday morning the unforeseen
medical symptoms have been preventing
her from performing so the songstress is
cancelling her dates that were
originally scheduled from november 5th
to november 21st and january 19th to
february 5th if you guys had tickets i'm
really sorry well i really hope she's
okay but selfishly i'm like so
relieved because november 5th like brian
had tickets in vegas but it is your
birthday and i would never miss your
birthday so i said no brian i can't go
to this amazing once in a lifetime
chance because i love my sister more
than life itself and now i got cancelled
so i didn't have to go didn't have to
make the choice
um this is really like concerning i hope
everything is truly okay i have to
cancel so many shows i know and like
i'm not saying that what she that she's
lying but like you know when when
celebrities release things like this
they always have a reason and it's
always something else and it's none of
our business so i really hope that
whatever is actually going on because i
don't think it's muscle spasms
these i don't know if that would take a
month you know i really really hope
she's okay like she's a queen she gives
us so much yeah she is the soundtrack of
our lives and like whatever time she
needs like we will give her the time and
the grace i just really i hope she's
okay yeah take the time all the time
that she needs plus like her
performances are so like obviously
vocally she gives us everything and more
and just basically emotionally and so
she needs to always be operating at like
100 you know she can't really there's no
phoning it in when you're celine dion so
i understand like you know if not
everything is is working properly then
we need to postpone and let's re like
remind remember she's been doing this
for so long
she's been through so much if she needs
time off she needs time off and she does
not need to give me an explanation i
also feel like in this day and age like
people postponing tours
residencies concert dates like so common
it's so common and it's like okay what's
another six-month wait right no because
of kobe like we all got our money back
and we saw like the world didn't end so
now like people are just like shifting
canceling adding shows it's like it's
actually lovely like it's much more
flexible now yeah it is and it seems
like less of a big deal like when
someone used to like cancel a tour it
would be like worldwide news and now
it's just maybe like you know
covet stuff they just like use it as an
excuse now probably as well but it must
be a relief for them that it's like they
don't have to up in their whole business
oh yeah like if i'm canceling a show due
to poor ticket sales i'm 100 percent
saying it's because of coving 100
someone in the venue has coveted like
just know like if i ever cancel a show
i'm going to regret saying this it's
because nobody bought tickets like
that's the only reason to cancel a show
unless like i break my life no or like
maybe something came up in your say the
ticket sales were like mess something
came up that you'd rather be doing
and you like there's other reasons
because las vegas nevada dirty jeans
canceling because of ticket sales no
okay so like literally i was supposed to
go no definitely not i was supposed to
do a show in vegas and it was like such
a big push i was on a billboard in vegas
and when we launched
it's like a thousand person theater i
sold 100 tickets and they were very like
to vegas is a weird market you sell the
tickets two weeks before like that's
just how it goes because people don't
know they're going to vegas until
they're in and i understand that but
like you have to understand how my
business works like the toasters the
patreon like we are prepared like we get
our tickets
months in advance i don't have a good
feeling about this and i'm not traveling
six hours when i was going to vegas for
my birthday
remember my 25th oh my god i'm so old
25th birthday ocean's 25.
and then i was gonna have to go back to
vegas like two weeks later i'm like i'm
not like killing myself just to get no
offense to see a hundred people how
pathetic is that so my cancel and the
hundred people were upset and i'm sorry
but like but it was coveted
thank you
it was there was a deadly illness
penetrating through the mirage yeah so
what can you do and i had like this
gorgeous out of her hands and this like
gorgeous wall that was like bob saget
amy schumer like
claudia
you should have just done the show just
really just for that i just didn't want
to wait it out like i'm sure more
tickets i'm sure i could have gotten to
like 500 by
the time of the show but like i hate
performing in front of half-filled rooms
it's depressing trust me i've done it a
lot casino rama ooh that was dark
where's that
outside of toronto it's in rama ontario
i honestly i don't even know where it is
but that sounds right yeah and it was
like a half filled room and there was a
bunch of toasters there but there was
also see when you play casinos you get
such great deals like why wouldn't you
play a casino like rooms and and you
like casinos are just filled with money
so they're paying you more than
than madison square garden like so
casinos are the best
but you
especially in like this remote part of
town like i'm doing parks casino this
time around and it's sold out already
because like that's by philly so i know
everyone who's coming it's a toaster but
when you perform a casino you get out on
the casino email list yeah to like the
vips that you know the locals and so
when i was in casino rama i would say
there was
probably like 800 people there in a
place that filled 3000 so it felt very
small and i would say about 200 of them
were toasters and the rest were just
like what is this did they enjoy
themselves you know what i've done worse
shows like i think i really captivated
the people who had no idea like who i am
or what i was doing you have to know who
you're talking to because if i'm in a
toasty crowd i can just be like rdh and
then we'll be like yeah but like if i'm
in front of normal human beings and
they're like rdh like what you have to
like explain it yeah so
i'm not to make this whole celine dion
shut down about myself i just do have a
lot of theatrical experience sorry
but the good news is sure world tour is
still scheduled to resume on march 9th
so she'll be back on the road if you
want to go see her i'm following her
around for sure yeah
it's crazy that that was
the last concert that i've been to so
she's going back out on march 9th we
literally went to her concert on march
5th it will be two years that she'll be
that's insane off the road that's
insanity i'm so excited to get to a
concert like that's really what i miss
most
in life if you're not gonna come to luke
homes like next month right no
and that kills me i'm gonna have to go
i'm gonna have to write your phone out
put my phone in a drawer and like not
ever look like i will literally have
tears in my eyes every time snitch goes
to a concert that like i would you know
have wanted to go to it is the hardest
thing for me that's the only thing that
gives me fomo and that's like the what
i'm so looking forward to doing
when i come in yeah i mean
not to rub it in i'm so [ __ ] excited
for lou comes two nights we're going on
both nights at madison square garden
they're just like so proud of my friend
luke first of all allowed to talk about
it okay fine that's fair like you know
100 when i'm not on the show
talk about it it's just that is going to
look at you mean what i just didn't
break my heart i wouldn't i don't i did
i said you said you i couldn't talk
about it i didn't say one word
i just made an exciting gesture to the
camera i'm allowed to be
excited okay i'm done
okay next story kristen cavallari is
calling her split with jay cutler
probably the best decision that she ever
made on caitlyn brothers podcast yes
kristen cavallari went on off the vine
and she is opening up about her split
with jay cutler saying it was probably
the brightest and saddest time of her
life she said there's been times over
the last 18 months where i'm like is
this the right decision jay and i
actually went on a couple of dates like
months and months and months ago she was
like we did but then i was like it's not
there for me anymore so i guess they
split up and then like she was having
second the thoughts and so she was like
let's see each other each other again
and it was like nope she said the thing
with jay is we aren't getting our
divorce because of love lost which made
it really challenging because we were
crazy about each other and so i just
decided i didn't want to be in a toxic
relationship anymore and i had to break
it off but that's made it hard and made
me sit here and question it for a few
months but then going back and dating
him a little bit made me reaffirm it
like no i know that i'm doing the right
thing then also she talks about
what we've been we're talking about this
week like the divorce and her children
and like what is the right
path and she said that she wanted her
kids to see her happy and believes that
they're better off with their parents
going their separate ways she said i
don't want my kids growing up thinking
that this is a good relationship because
i got to see my mom get remarried and in
a good relationship so i knew what one
was right
so an interesting pov on this discussion
yeah and she also was basically like if
we didn't have kids i would never see
this man again but like i have to
and honestly that's that you know what
she's so funny no because you know what
like that did you ever see marriage
story no is that what it was called yeah
what's that one on hbo right now scenes
of america okay
it was like these two people just
[ __ ] hated each other so [ __ ] much
and it's like you hate someone that much
you would never want to see them but you
have to see them every [ __ ] day
they're in your life forever they are
your family divorce is
so difficult like i
i can't imagine like and
that's what she was saying like
basically i think she's saying he's a
[ __ ] nut and i've now come to you
know realize that and i never want to
see him again oh but we share um three
kids and we see each other every day
yeah so i didn't get to the part where
she calls like alludes to that he's a
[ __ ] man well that's just what i
gathered from the clips that i saw and
from what you just said she was in a
toxic relationship like
interesting
interesting
i mean you know part of me will always
ship what can i say no me too i thought
they were a great couple and like they
had a show her show and like even though
he definitely like came off weird sorry
that wasn't the fifth story i don't know
why i'm putting putting right away
getting excited i i know it's always the
best feeling when i can tuck it away um
their relationship always like came off
as like really funny and quirky on the
show not like other relationships not
like well probably like a ton of others
but it like worked for them you know and
the fact that they were like showing you
that side of like jay and heard it's
like okay so that's good yeah but it
wasn't good
you know yeah but you know what a plus
uh reporting from caitlyn russo yeah
great guests great questions making news
you'd love to see podcasts making
headlines you absolutely do
are you ready now for our fifth and
final story
so delivery outside the door for us yes
it's a stove it's a stove oh i think i
know what that is oh i know what that is
it's a new sponsor and it's [ __ ]
sickening oh wow it's like an outdoor
fire pit
shut up obviously not for we won't be we
can use it in the studio right in front
of us but um isn't that cool that is
cool we'll tell you guys about it when
when it's time when we get the promo
code um our fifth and final story we're
just gonna go right into it because
there's gonna be a lot of music in this
story
but wait what yeah we're just going
right in because i already went in okay
we're getting our first look at taraji p
henson as ms hannigan manny live it's
been a few weeks since we got an annie
live update yeah and now we are seeing
miss hannigan
in her oh my god she looks great we will
post this to our instagram is any a
christmas movie
no why is she holding a christmas
ornament well it's coming out december
2nd and maybe annie does celebrate
christmas at the war boxes
santa claus what's that jose
that was like a good orphan voice
amazing yeah
so this is really exciting just because
i think it means like more annie content
coming soon it's been a while since we
got excited about annie even though you
know what it's my job to be honest with
you i know that we have overhyped this
no nothing i was going to say i just
think i've lost a lot of the joie de
vivre that i had for annie i did too
once we started telling other people
about it and other people and hearing it
out loud yeah not within the confines of
this studio they were like that's they
were like nicole scherzinger nothing of
the sort from the pussycats why not hugh
jackman literally so i agree i've
definitely lost some of my zest for
annie but i want to get it back because
it was exciting to be excited about
something and what is it when and where
is it premiering december 2nd on nbc
annie live
any live we're going to give it we
should do like a live stream while we
watch it like we've talked about it for
so [ __ ] long i know
we have to like go on instagram live and
watch it separately like in our
christmas pajamas we have to do
something special for you yeah because
well we should host like a screening
like at a bar oh you can't go to a bar
that would be really sad
no checking i'm telling you it would be
the best night of our lives
we would all sing along you know yeah
i just want anything
i'll come out tomorrow pick your bottom
dollar that tomorrow and then all the
toasters will be like they'll be sun
yeah i just hope that if anybody is
watching who's responsible for annie
live like please make it good because we
have a lot riding on this at this point
emotionally physically yeah i just
i don't know if i can handle this crowd
i don't know if i can handle a big
letdown like that
um okay well those are the best five
stories and i feel as though you needed
to know some of them yeah you needed to
know
none of that
you needed to know that lala and randall
there's still hope
um and we've got our tv recap which is
chock full of goodness which is brought
to you by current
i'm sorry my phone is frozen just give
me one second if you if you can
current is a technology company that
lets you manage your money on your phone
they believe banking should be more
accessible and affordable with no
surprises and no minimum balances
current's easy to use app and debit card
gives you flexibility freedom and faster
access to your money they have benefits
like earning points when you swipe with
your debit card at eligible merchants
redeemable for cash back they have no
fees on over 40 000 in network all point
atms in the us they have helpful
spending insights and notifications to
track when and where you're spending and
they have easy to create savings goals
that include ability to round up
purchases to save extra change and if
you get a current premium account you
can enjoy direct deposit up to two days
early and an overdraft of up to 100
without overdraft fees so for a limited
time we are partnering with current to
give away a thousand dollars that's
right current is going to give away 250
to four listeners of our show all you
have to do is download the current app
and enter code toast during sign up for
a chance to win remember that's code
toast during sign up the winners will be
awarded soon so don't wait download the
current app and sign up in less than two
minutes and enter code toast for a
chance to win that 250 if four people
are gonna win visit current.com toast
for full terms and conditions
great okay let's talk about only murders
in the building okay okay because
it's tenth episode premiered we know who
killed tim cono spoiler
major spoilers here because the show is
over and now we're going to be talking
about it
okay so jan's a killer
and to be honest like
i really didn't see that coming
and even like last week's episode when
it was like she's not the first
bassoonist and they found the bassoon
cleaner i'm like there must be some sort
of explanation and then it really did
turn out to be her and she was very good
actress like very diabolical loved it
all loved the ending like him being on
the drugs and honestly when he stood up
out of that hysterical so funny um but
the thing is with this show is like i
honestly don't even care who like when
you watch a thriller like i was just
watching clickbait and i could not wait
to get to the end i'm like how does the
show end
i don't even care like i just love
watching these people like you know go
on this journey like i'm not so invested
in like who did what and now i'm i see
people trying to put together well who
killed
bunny
if
he was riding the sweatshirt and she
stumbled in like i don't care like i
just can't wait for next season to see
the game get back together yeah so i
loved the way that it ended for two
reasons i thought that the murderer was
very like a satisfying ending and it
made a lot of sense and also now
watching it back there were so many
clues and you know especially because
like once we found out he was poisoned
and you know they do say poison is a
women's weapon
so we should have been able to narrow it
down so i think that felt very satiating
that like
that was a good killer makes sense wraps
it up nicely someone that we know not
just like some friend character yeah
that they throw in so that was great and
then two it opened it up for season two
i thought maybe this was just gonna be a
limited series but now we're gonna get
more murders in the building i would
have loved to have seen like some of the
podcast success like yeah they get a
sponsor like is oliver in good financial
standing right because the demons
obviously aren't sponsoring the show
anymore so he got that 30k from
teddy
um but then for their finale like they
should have sold it for like you know at
least 50k and like i just need oliver to
keep his apartment no i know and like
now
they're like
under arrest so i'm like are they gonna
be able to operate their business and
like now tina fey's like coming in
trying to steal their podcast like
making a podcast about them but like it
was their thing yeah i mean i'm sure
they'll get out and they'll do their
podcast um
in season two i just wanna i just
i'm worried about their financial
standing
not um brazos
not brazos
when he like was like i'm doing stage
sips i was like yes brazos and then the
handkerchief like oh no brazos and it
was just a very exciting show i loved it
yeah it was so good it was so well done
it was so funny selena gomez was amazing
like i just have a new
outlook on her same and she's such a
great actress and she's just a great gal
like i was just loving her i followed
her on tick tock this morning like i
love selena gomez yeah i never thought
i'd say that but she hasn't been doing
that much promo for the show because i
was looking at her instagram she doesn't
really talk about it literally like if i
were her i would be shouting from the
rooftops this is a work of art this is
the best thing she's done in years if
ever like it's also the best show in the
years so like the fact that it's
her thing it's it's so cool and there's
just really something to be said for
steve martin and martin martin short
putting out i know they've accomplished
so much this is one of the best things
i've ever seen them in and you know
they're both well into their 60s like
yeah it you just love to see two
comedians killing it and they're it's
just so contemporary like in it on the
nose and like you know the podcast
element it just really and then enjoy
the cringy emily and paris way it's hard
for
shows to like capture the essence of a
lot of these like new age things
and they did it in the best way that
i've seen so i i love books and shows
and movies that are about podcasts it
just gives so much credence to the art
it gives so much
credence to the art i i couldn't say it
better i don't know why i was trying um
okay so i'm like sad it's over but i
really that was just like a fun journey
and i might even watch it again like
yeah and you know what i did watch it
like two every two weeks like
episodically and it kind of makes it
more even though it's frustrating you
just want to know what happens it does
make you do feel more involved than when
you binge it and like because even last
night i realized i had two episodes to
watch and like
i was like binging it so that we could
talk about it today and it's like
when you binge something you do sort of
like miss out on how you feel between
episodes like where who you thought did
it before you knew this like
it's nice to have some time to reflect
and and it becomes more
[Music]
in your head yeah
for sure
um
vanderpump rules
so
here's the thing oh wait i want to ask
you about last week's episode because do
you agree with me about james and raquel
yeah i think they're so [ __ ] cute and
nice and like honestly
i just don't understand why he keeps
saying it's a tiffany's ring when it's
not from tiffany's
um it's like a tiffany's diamond from
his friend so i just need more
clarification i'm sure and he will dive
into that at the reunion he asked them
and watch what happens live still no
clarification they maintain that it's a
tiffany's diamond with a setting from
his friend like so what's a tiffany's
diamond i don't know like maybe
it's like
secondhand
oh that's the only thing like you know
not that he got it like from the real
real but like no but like a vintage ring
that was from tiffany's and you had
diamond is fine and you had to reset and
he had it reset that's i don't know why
reasonable but the thing is they didn't
explain it that way so maybe that's not
the case that's the only thing i can
think of that makes this like logical
that's a great explanation they should
go with that i think they're great i
think that the um
proposal was so sweet
and really beautifully done i don't
understand why tom sandoval paid for
half of it and like when him and ariana
were having that conversation is she
saying like now she will get married
i think she was saying like if you know
he did all of that she would say yes to
an engagement that doesn't necessarily
mean she wants to get married yeah
yeah just like
i just cannot stand tom sandoval he was
probably the worst version of himself i
think i don't think he's ever looked
worse than an episode than last night's
episode i think the last time he looked
that bad was that saucy's book signing
where he was an animal and you know what
who came out of the hero of last night's
episode
ariana ari [ __ ] anna because you know
what i of course i love people who like
stand by their man but you know what
sometimes your man needs to be told that
he's being wrong and when it comes to
mariana i do think it holds a lot of
weight as opposed to coming from katie
or tom now the quote of the episode is
tom sandoval but it's also tom
[ __ ] schwartz i cannot stand
this man i don't know how katie does
like if my husband ever threw me under
the bus the a fraction of the amount of
times that tom schwartz says i would
suck him in the face first of all
second of all that conversation was so
painful like
basically what tom's trying to say is
like i don't feel comfortable working
with you on the restaurant because in
the past you've proven that you send me
text messages yeah or that like you're
unprofessional in professional
situations but first of all like that's
the show that's the job and it hasn't
been that heated and crazy for years and
also you should [ __ ] hope that your
restaurant is relevant enough to bring
in this sort of truth
yeah no and like if that's what's going
if what happened in the last six years
is going on at your restaurant that
means your restaurant is a success and
you know what i just feel like it's so
unfair of tom to like be throwing yes
she was katie was problematic a couple
years ago and i think she would admit
that like tequila katie she was like
getting really angry when she was drunk
and like being mean and i feel like she
doesn't do that anymore so to to bring
something up ariana was literally like
you're talking about something that
happened six years ago like it's
irrelevant it's so unfair like if
somebody's making progress and like
you're bringing up this old thing like
that's not fair i like i actually hate
when people do that it bothers me so
much right as if people can't grow and
change and that even if they do it it
doesn't matter they're always going to
be you're always going to be thinking it
by your worst moment and everyone on the
show has had completely awful moments
like if that's if we never moved on from
them and that's really the one of the
things that so
makes the show work so well weirdly is
that they do these awful things to each
other to themselves and then
tabby larassa they're really able to
move on from it so if you want to get
stuck in the mud from six years ago that
doesn't work on this show so you told me
that they came up with a different name
what was it i did did someone else tell
me every week i watch what happens live
andy asks everyone who's on the guest
like what they should name it because
you not tell me that they had a name
i don't know
whiskey whiskey whiskey tom
tom
some people were suggesting that it be
called like
ariana cariana something with the girls
names and then i'm sure tom sandoval
will love that oh my god katie maloney
suggested once upon a time oh that's
what you told me and that's cute that's
so cute you know what katie is actually
a great businesswoman she grew up in
restaurants she like runs her own
successful business she's very good with
digital she takes lots of photos she's
very artsy i don't think that her being
involved would be the worst thing and
honestly this whole situation would go
away if tom schwartz like had any balls
he'd be like this is my wife it's our
business she's obviously being involved
[ __ ] off he's so annoying the dynamic
between the two of them like it used to
be like this cute thing when they were
just like a
a
a c line plot of the show but now that
it's a line and it's like when they were
sitting in palm springs and tom schwartz
was like you did such an amazing job on
the
rochelle i'm gonna give you the name i
was like yeah okay that was so
unbelievably lame and and also this like
thing tom sandoval being extra and he
came over with that basket like full of
vagina candles like
and the face mask so he did that's not a
personality trait i'm sorry
the show
is being ruined for me like i could not
i can't like so for me like the rochelle
stuff and like him being so extra about
james's engagement and then like when it
all went well he was like we did it it's
like
no it was nothing to do with this it was
really weird it was so weird it was so
illusory and also like
he thinks that he is the main character
he is single-handedly ruining the show
i
it's shocking to me like it's so [ __ ]
cringy i want to jump out of here i know
he's awful like really awful and then so
not only does he do so if he wants to
you know spend twelve thousand five
hundred dollars on james's engagement
while also taking like a mortgage out on
his house i can't watch people who make
such dumb financial mistakes like make
those financial decisions like that's
one thing but then he also acts like an
absolute psychopath later in the episode
to katie and now i'm like oh okay so
you're annoying and you're evil goodbye
it's like you're actually making really
bad decisions like the name the finances
like you're like actually if there's any
reason that this restaurant isn't like
successful or taking off yet is because
you are in charge like that's why so to
come at katy who's just trying to be
helpful and i get it's annoying when
like when you have ideas and someone
like is being constructive and it's just
like basically tearing your ideas down
but a bad idea is a bad idea also they
have tomtom which is like a swanky west
hollywood joint that's named after them
if they want this new restaurant to be a
little bit different and stand apart
like they should incorporate their wives
they should make it like if so it's like
lisa would always say and i actually
thought it was a good reference she
would say
villa blanc is where you take your wife
sir is where you take your mistress pump
is where you take your boyfriend and
then i think tom time would be where you
take your girlfriends yeah and
once upon a time should be where you go
on a double date like yeah you know fun
group fun so jenga
he should be leaning into things that
make this different from tom tom because
i don't know that there's that enough to
go around in this day and age of people
who want to go to tomtom part two and
they just after sir and pump and bill
and people who want to go to town town
but like couldn't get in that night yeah
no i mean this restaurant story line is
actually so uninteresting just because
sandoval's taking it over but the sheena
and brock thing is actually really
interesting and like i do feel really
bad for sheena and also like i kind of
like like brock like i think that he
brings good energy and i do think he's
100 right about gina's mom like
i get that it's your mom but like if
we're paying someone on salary like
i can wake up early and go to the gym
and play pickleball because we have
someone on salary like and it's just
awkward that it's sheena's mom
but like
that's what it is yeah that that didn't
bother me so much about him when i said
that last week like him going to play
pickleball like because he's like
striving to win and do his best with the
group
it was cute to me cute cute like but so
i actually really did side with him on
like the sheena's mom stuff and
obviously it's [ __ ] weird that he
hasn't seen his kids in four years and
like
i guess okay two years there are the
pandemics like two years but he moved to
america to have a better life like he
wasn't living like in the desert he was
living in australia like no and also he
they said he moved to america to have a
give a better life to his kids but like
is he sending money is he sending money
home to australia is his wife former
wife accepting money because she has a
new
husband i don't know who's married and
who's not but
is there money being exchanged otherwise
you're just in america for yourself yeah
it feels like he moved to america and
like is relieved of the fact that his
ex-wife has a new husband he really
filled in like the stepper dad role and
like the kids are being taken care of
yeah but like it's bizarre and i really
want to like him like i actually think
he's like funny and i like when he like
when he's talking about how his thighs
are so big at soul cycle like i like i
think he's very different and
interesting but i cannot get past this
and lala's 100 right to like should be
telling sheen all this because i know
sheena doesn't want to hear her but
china knows that she's right too yeah
and how strange about summer and winter
oh my god
lala was like if
if my husband ever left and named her
his kid lake it's so weird it's crazy
and like sheena's lying that she always
wants to name her kids summer because
she know we know she wanted to name her
kid madison murray parks valletta but
she said that that was rob's name that's
what she said on montreal's live because
of course like andy asked her yeah do
you see james and raquel on watch what
happens live last night i watched like
up until the first commercial break and
they were they were doing a lot first of
all raquel found her voice
she said that katie is getting involved
in the business because she's born at
home
not good that's also just like not
correct not good and she has a very
successful podcast she also said that um
they're just like completely team tom
the two of them and of course they have
to be they were asked about la la and
randall and james said he really didn't
know anything
but every time like andy asked a shady
question which it should just be called
shh like watch shade with nola
live
watch shades
and
james like always like
hesitated was like about to give like
the shady answer and then like said the
nice thing because i don't think he
wants issues with lala but like there's
something something there yeah i mean
like i really do like james and raquel
and you know tom sandoval is actually so
far up james's ass of course james would
be on his side um
i'm so team katie like it hurts yeah no
i'm i'm so team katie this season just
on every level like she's being
hilarious she's being hilarious like
no one wants to be there least of all
her and she's just giving us everything
by giving us nothing but you know what
it was really interesting just to hear
even lisa
um
mention stassi and jax and brittany like
it was crazy because and she was and you
know what i think a lot of us have
wondered like if katie wants kids and
it's real i'm like really sad for her
that she like had spent a lot of kobe
trying and never got there and it's just
like
people are so annoying when they ask
that question but hearing lisa
like even just speak of like the dead
the cast members i'm like what it was
crazy it was shocking and it was like i
was glad that she said it because it's
like we're all thinking obviously
it's one thing if it was just sheena and
lala like those aren't even katie's
closest friends but when you add in
britney and sassy yes everyone around
her did just have a baby and we just do
need to acknowledge that yeah in telling
the whole story yeah i thought that was
and then also they were referring back
to sassy's book signing like it was just
crazy to hear her name yeah it it was
um okay so that was vader from girls and
then impeachment jackie it's so [ __ ]
good and last night's episode was the
part where like the media
takes on monica and it was so sad and it
really got me thinking like two things
one how wonderful that there was no
internet because she was glued to the
television like watching late night and
like it's so crazy because this was like
not even long ago and the things that
like jay leno and like dave letterman
who everyone's like dave letterman the
things they were saying like we're so
[ __ ] evil and it's just it's not even
like it was that long ago but the fact
that there was no internet is such a
blessing for monica like i can't imagine
how much worse it could have been but
like
they they did an snl skate about monica
and linda and like
linda was like this heavy woman and like
john goodman played her and like you
just see linda like linda's the [ __ ]
worst but like you see her in her house
watching john goodman pretend to be her
and like it's so sad
so while it's crazy i mean it's so much
better that it happened
without the internet i do think a lot of
the [ __ ] that you know
that flew back in the 90s would never
have flown today like the narrative just
basically being like you know monica's
legs monica this monica that one it's
like no bill build this build that yeah
so i think that like it would have been
better if it had happened now but it
also would have been worse because of
the internet so it's like more content
but the narrative would never have been
like you know
bill clinton could get any man in the
world and he wanted man i got like
gross like [ __ ] like that and it was
just beatni did a really good job um
it's it was actually a really sad
episode that's making me really sad they
put on like on the tv like the real snl
skit i had never seen it molly shannon
played
monica and john goodman played linda
tripp and it was actually really sad to
watch like and beanie monica like was i
couldn't get off she had to watch
everything like she couldn't stop
and yeah it's just so good like i really
recommend it
there's three more episodes i'm gonna
try and like batch them up but i'm just
and ben is hooked
i'm gonna i'll watch maybe when there's
two left so that i can like come in and
slide right into home that's nice
um so that's really all she wrote you
have anything else you want to say
before my departure i'm heading
to roma no we wish you safe travels
we'll be having a great time we look
forward to seeing all the content that
abe captures for you thank you so much
and just you know enjoy your your time
off and enjoy hosting with ben it's
always a roller coaster it's full of
highs and lows that it is you know what
i do not envy you because when i host
with men people like say the meanest
things about me yeah but that's
different energy yeah you know well i'm
excited to watch you and ben i think
it'll be great yeah and i'll be back on
tuesday but jackie will be back tomorrow
our stable queen and thank you so much
for listening to the morning shows
monday morning show where we deliver the
best stories that you need each and
every monday friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
click to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up what's available as podcasts
and we're podcasting we found so spotify
i didn't catch your public radio i
already started all the places where
there's not guess what it's more
interesting faster i mean without
beautiful stunning support we are well
that was the fastest i've ever done it
yeah if you made it to the end of the
episode why don't you drop an emoji on
our most recent instagram how about the
bowl of spaghetti in honor of my trip to
italia and i'll bring you back some
spaghetti love you guys bye